la décision a été annoncée hier soir par
edouard philippe la france est à l'arrêt
pour préparer l'arrivée du stade iii de
l'épidémie du corps à la virus à
fermeture des bars des boîtes de nuit
des restaurants ou encore des cinémas l
élu public non indispensables
conséquence la ruée vers les commerces
alimentaires écouter ses réactions
ben moi je ne cède pas à la panique
parce que je prends des précautions mais
le problème c'est que les gens ils
créent eux mêmes leurs problèmes et ils
cèdent à la panique après c'est la dèche
il n'y a plus rien on croirait que c'est
la panique c'est la fin du monde
il n'ya presque pratiquement plus rien
les gens ils s'acharnent sur les pattes
sur les gâteaux et tout ça mais
franchement c'est la dèche
on se demande s'il va voir vraiment la
fin du monde j'ai fini par devoir le
faire je viens de prendre une dizaine de
paquets de pâtes alors que depuis le
début je critique cette façon de faire
mais au final j'ai pas le choix car j'ai
passé ma journée entière à chercher un
malheureux stack de pâtes
j'ai fait cinq supermarchés encore moi
j'habite vers la place d'auteuil vers la
porte d'auteuil pardon est impossible de
trouver des pâtes ou les rayons
dévaliser les sauces les machins là j'ai
même pas vu trouvé une boîte de sauce
bolognaise donc j'ai pris au moins des
pâtes un petit peu de ketchup et voilà
pour essayer de survivre comme les
autres puisque des gens font des stocks
s'ils courent maintenant stupide
puisqu'ils vont stocker 200 250 paquets
de pâtes chez eux donc ils nous auront
aucune utilité